you were in solitary confinement for ten
and a half months ten and a half months
that seems like torture and I
experienced some miraculous things in
solitary I'm freaking out I'm in a Cell
I'm freaking out I'm like what the hell
and I had a Bible in my hand I said I
need you to speak with me so I closed my
eyes I opened the Bible I point to a
random verse and the verse was I am
yours and you are mine I have redeemed
you and called you by name oh Jacob
oh yeah
[Music]
thank you
sometimes in politics one sits on the
sidelines sometimes one grabs the bull
by the horns sometimes one wears the
bull horns
as we have in the case of my guest today
Jacob chansley
sometimes called the Q Anon Shaman
sometimes called the horn hat guy
I will just call you Jacob Jacob thank
you for coming on the show thank you for
having me now before we begin this
episode is brought to you by expressvpn
go check out expressvpn.com Michael y t
today
Jacob
we're here in Phoenix Arizona
we're in Phoenix because you are not
presently permitted to leave the state
you have gotten out of prison you've
gotten out of a halfway house now we're
sitting in a warehouse in Arizona how'd
you get here
well
um I drove
but you're not you're you're out of
prison you're you're but there are still
issues that are working their way
through the courts yes yes so my lawyer
filed a motion to vacate my conviction
and my sentence due to the fact that the
footage that was on Tucker Carlson was
not in the discovery that was given to
my previous defense attorney because the
story about you and the footage that we
all saw is that you led a violent
Insurrection a coup d'etat on January
6th and you were kicking your way
through
barricades and you were I don't know
going to take over the country make
yourself Emperor and then we saw this
footage that showed that you were kind
of just walking through the capitol
flanked it seemed by police officers it
was just totally different from what the
media had said
are you allowed to talk about it I don't
well because of the motion in the courts
my attorney has advised me not to say
too much at all regarding that because
litigation sucks and it's it's a long
process and the government will will and
can use anything you say and twist it to
make you look a certain way that is
gonna give more Credence to their case
but I assure you there's a very good
reason why they would escort to me very
good reason but I can't talk about it
okay but you can at least talk about
what led you to the capital with the
horns with the face paint
how'd you how'd you end up there well
I've been dressing this way for over 10
years
this is a shamanic regalia okay the the
the feds haven't given me back my
original headdress they still have my
headdress they still have the I had to
make this this is a replacement yes the
feds still have your they still have the
original the coyote skins the coyote
Tails all of that stuff they also have
my staff
they have my phone they still have all
that stuff and they're not going to give
it back until this motion has processed
through the courts but you've been
wearing this for 10 years yes I've been
wearing this regalia for over 10 years
um the original regalia was made of
coyote skin and coyote Tails now in the
dnae OR Navajo tradition the coyote is
the trickster or the deceiver so I have
the trickster by the Tails I'm wearing
the trickster skin because if the
trickster messes with the Buffalo he
gets the horns you see what I'm saying
so there's always symbolism in
everything it is that I do and I'm
practicing an ancient form of uh heoka
Shamanism in one way or another it's
almost like a a way of shocking the
cognitive system through imagery through
an appearance and that cognitive shock
allows the hayoka shaman to come to the
tribesmen come to the people and say hey
your cultural Paradigm is not what
reality actually is
so you you wore this on January 6th and
before that two shock people
well kind of it's more so like first of
all hyoka also dressed this way to shock
or or chase away evil spirits it's a
matter of being intimidating to evil to
evil spirits to evil presences to evil
Vibes so it's about uh being
intimidating to evil while at the same
time shocking the cognitive system that
is this pre-programmed
neuro-linguistically programmed system
of cultural paradigms culture is
programming right it's an operating
system like a computer and so as human
beings we need to upgrade our operating
system in order to fully understand what
reality is all about
so now I want to get to the January 6
Capital stuff
but I gotta ask how did you get into
shamanism
well I've always been interested in it
ever since I was a kid you know I knew
like the Native American Shaman the guys
wearing the headdresses and the face
paint or the you know the horns and
stuff I was like they know something
they're they're pounding their drum
they're singing their songs they're
dancing they're drinking you know peyote
tea or eating mushrooms like what do
they know like why would somebody do
that so I was very curious from a very
early age and I got into it really got
into the shamanic path
um after I got out of the Navy and then
it really like started full like head on
going into it just diving right in in
2012.
I think a lot of people don't even know
that you were in the Navy
so thank you for your service
my pleasure I think this whole interview
is just going to be a series of
rewinding because the story gets more
interesting right and the further back
you go
it's a very patriotic normal kind of
thing to do is to join the Navy so this
is pre-shaman stuff why'd you join the
Navy well because I wanted to serve God
and Country
then tell me about the shift you're in
the Navy you get out why'd you get out
well I refused the anthrax vaccine so
because I refuse the anthrax vaccine
they gave me a general discharge under
honorable conditions it's like I never
joined I don't get my uh GI Bill but I
also don't get a tainted record right so
I was refusing vaccines before it was
cool well I I've heard the anthrax
vaccine is also
the most painful one among my military
vet friends and so you were skeptical of
the vaccine what what didn't you like
about the vaccines well I did research
you know I looked into it I didn't just
trust the government which I don't think
anybody should just trust the government
you know they uh have a history of not
being trustworthy
um there are people that were crippled
due to blood clots in their legs there
are people that actually died from it
there's all sorts of negative effects
and it's not just one shot the anthrax
vaccine is a series of shots kind of
like the coveted one
so you say okay I'm anti-vaxx but it was
from the physical threats of it it
wasn't a say a religious opposition to
it or something like that well once I
really started to do research on
vaccines and the people that are pushing
them and making money off of them it
really became clear that there was
ulterior motive not just in the military
but abroad well I I remember when the
coveted vaccines came out
we were told that they're totally fine
they're very effective they're very safe
and so they made all these scientific
claims that turned out to be a little
bit dubious but also the vaccines were
produced from research that involved
aborted
yeah and so
plenty people had religious objections
to it I didn't know I assumed that one
could get out of that requirement for
their work or even in the military
with a religious exemption but but a lot
of people were denied those exemptions
so in any case you were not given an
exemption you were you were told take
the anthrax vax or you're out of the
Navy you get out of the Navy then you
say you got into some of the shaman
stuff
now forgive my Prejudice but it would
seem if you joined the Navy you're
probably like a clean-cut normal
American kid if you get into Shaman
stuff that's usually sounds a little
more hippy-dippy not not the image that
I have of a service member did something
change in your life here or no is my
Prejudice just wrong well join the
military and tell me if you think people
in the military are normal fair enough
fair fair enough there's a lot of good
people in the military but there's also
a lot of strange ones it's an Eclectic
yeah very eclectic okay so then how did
you get into it
well
I have have become very dissatisfied
with modern religious Dogma and in
Shamanism the main thing about Shamanism
is personal experience
so what is your personal experience of
God what's your personal experience of
the spirit world what is your personal
experience of uh life in general the
interconnection that we all have to
Nature how how what's your personal
experience of nature what's your
personal experience of
um vibes from people
you know what I'm saying so it's much
more oriented around personal experience
now yes there is tradition absolutely
but the tradition is largely there as
almost like scaffolding to build up in
this personal experience structure of
understanding how reality works works
through personal experience were you
raised with any particular religious uh
yeah my mother tried raising my brothers
and I Catholic
and then she thought better of it
because you know I I was cradle Catholic
then I became an atheist for like 10
years and then I got a little bit
hippy-dippy on my spiritual thoughts but
then I went back to being Catholic now
I'm
very old school traditional Latin Mass
so it's either I do have a kind of
personal interest in this you're raised
Catholic
didn't take though so sometime in your
childhood when I became a teenager
teenage okay it's kind of the same for
me and then you say okay I don't want
the traditional stuff I don't want the
rigidity I want more of a personal
experience type religion
now is there attention because on the
one hand
you say You're really taken with doing
your own research maybe scientific
studies on the vaccines you're asking
these questions applying rigor applying
logic
uh that's how I would approach religion
where I'd say okay I've got certain
spiritual intuitions but I want to apply
rigor I want to apply to logic I want to
apply theology to it
but then when it comes to the religious
stuff you say no I
I want to throw off those shackles and
that rigidity and I want just a
totally
personalist kind of relationship to
religion well no no
um part of the reason why I rejected
Catholicism is because I did some
research
and I saw that the modern day Catholic
Church is a distillation of the ancient
Roman Empire
and that when the when Constantine
converted to Christianity on his
deathbed and he changed the Roman uh
Empire from being Pagan to being
Christian what they did is they just
grafted all the Pagan beliefs onto
Christianity and they used Christian
disciples and Jesus and all this other
stuff to replace all of the pagan gods
you know and all of the Pagan statues
but the the holidays remained the same
yeah I'm I've heard these arguments I'm
I'm not as taken with them I used to I
used to believe that uh like the dating
of Christmas for instance or Easter
these sorts of things I I I'm not
convinced by that any longer I think
that some of the arguments about say the
placement of Soul Invictus or mithris or
or the the Feast of the unconquered son
or whatever you're uh yeah exactly
um
that I don't think if you look at say
the chronography of 354 I don't think
that one could really argue that those
holidays particularly Soul Invictus
predates Christian Christianity and the
dating of Christmas I think there are
stronger Arguments for it in the other
way
um but perhaps I'll be able to convince
you on that later on for now it suffices
to say you've you've followed this more
shamanic kind of religious path uh how
old are you about this time well when I
really started to investigate Shamanism
I was about 20 years old okay but I had
had shamanic experiences since you know
before I hit puberty
what were those like well I after
watching the movie Jesus of Nazareth at
10 years old during spring break uh in
1997. I was very inspired uh to do my
own communion
and so I grabbed a bottle of wine from
the cabinet my parents weren't looking I
grabbed some bread and I blessed the
bread and blessed the wine and
um I caught a little bit of a buzz
because I kept drinking the wine but I
had a very deep and profound shamanic
experience I felt the presence of God
felt the Holy Spirit it came over me I
was crying a lot you know so that was my
first real shamanic experience of like
mixing uh religious ceremony with
Altered States Of Consciousness so that
that was where that started but um then
I had you know experiences throughout my
teenage years where I was uh
experimenting with cannabis and that
really was mind-blowing and I I had some
pretty profound experiences with that
that really answered all the questions
that I had ever had about reality and
God and who I was what life was about
what reality was all of that stuff but
it was all like a download I couldn't
actually articulate it like verbally to
anybody I just understood like
intuitively like instantly how
everything fits together could you
articulate it now oh yeah so what were
those insights
so are you familiar with the Fibonacci
sequence and the the spiral right okay
so and five the Phi ratio golden mean
all that okay so
long and short of it is is everything is
made up of interconnected
electromagnetic fields so everything is
a a like a hologram of these
interconnected electromagnetic fields on
different sizes and scales each of these
different electromagnetic fields is
operating based on this spiral of energy
from these higher Dimensions to the
lower Dimensions dispensing larger or
smaller amounts of energy to these
higher or lower Dimensions based on the
frequency of energy that each of these
electromagnetic fields is based
would you describe this as I've heard
these sorts of ideas described as a new
age no and that's what's interesting
about Shamanism and this is the reason
why I practice it is because if you look
into shamanic culture all religions are
basically practicing different forms of
shamanism so for example in Shamanism
they believe in one unified field a
spirit a great spirit Collective Soul
God you know Brahma Nirvana whatever you
want to call it right they also believe
in the idea of prayer and meditation and
getting in tune or in sync with this
deity with this with this Divine creator
that is one is one thing right they also
believe in the idea of like singing
dancing music right drumming okay and
the use of sound right they also believe
in healing miraculous healing they also
believe in things like sacraments and
the use of plants in the ecosystem that
are sacramental or or are uh sacred in
one way or another and they use them
either as incense or to consume them or
whatever to uh get in tune or in touch
with god with great spirit whatever you
want to call it
um and they also all believe in the
spirit world and this idea of life after
death
so what I've just described is every
religion on the planet
and so this is why I practice Shamanism
because it's the first religion it's the
it's the fir the first it's the
foundation of all religions
but all those religions are are
different they're distinct well yes and
no when you get down to the shamanic
roots of all of them they all
essentially believe in the same thing
they just have different labels and that
would make sense considering everybody
speaks different languages
okay I'm a little skeptical of this
because uh it seems to me the devil's in
the details always you know there were
similarities between uh Christianity and
Islam
maybe even between Christianity and
Buddhism but it seems to me there are
Stark differences too in the view of
who God is God is either part of the
world or separate from the world our
relation to him so I do wonder if there
are some distinctions here uh but but
the impulse at the very least in your
pull toward Shamanism is that it seems
to be
universalized yes Universal and and and
primitive in that it's a kind of
proto-religion that
in your mind uh has Parts in all of
these other religions
well but the thing is is it's really not
primitive and the reason why I say that
is because the shamans they understood
quantum physics before Quantum
physicists did they understood the rule
of sound uh the role of sound and the
rules of physics long before they were
ever discussed or discovered by Western
philosophers and physicists and they
they gained these understandings based
on personal experiences
you see now part of why Shamanism is so
important to me is because it's about
understanding what reality is how
reality works and how it is that we play
a role in that reality like the power of
manifestation for example or the law of
attraction and things of that nature so
so what is your role well you see so
like I was saying everything is made up
of these uh infinitely interconnected
electromagnetic fields of different
higher you know Dimensions times scales
of energy Etc
um so human beings are like right in the
middle between the extremely infinitely
small and the extremely infinitely large
and because we're kind of like right in
the middle we're like antenna for what
Quantum physicists call non-local
Consciousness they say that basically
Consciousness is not produced in the
brain through complex neural activity
but rather Consciousness is produced in
the universe like the laws of physics
and we are a antenna for that
Consciousness for that self-awareness
signal that permeates all things
and so our role then becomes one of
almost like co-creation that that it's
like reality is like 90 95 created and
then we have the choice free will to
choose which reality we wish to embody
based on the cycling of this energy so
if you look into the heart math
Institute and the role that frequencies
play on in our DNA and the activation of
antenna on our DNA that send and
received light and information then
you'll realize that these things send
and receive light and information with
non-local Consciousness or this larger
unified energetic field that is
conscious God is conscious right it's
God's service sure so the idea here is
that we are a part of this
interconnected whole and very similar to
how a computer can change things on the
Internet by changing the code of this
cloud of electromagnetic frequencies
right changing the code we as human
beings are like computers and it's like
this non-local Consciousness signal is
like Wi-Fi or the internet and so
through our thoughts through our
emotions through our words through our
actions we influence the code or the
Matrix of reality itself
now couldn't I just say that I'm a human
being and I've got free will and I do
something and when I do something when I
act in the world that changes the world
yes is that what you just said basically
okay okay so I totally agree with that
and therefore we do all have roles to
play in the world and we have given
circumstances but we can also act on
those circumstances and so you're
choosing to act of course politics and
political activism is a very specific
form of acting in order to change the
world at what point are you drawn to
political activism
well I consider it more so spiritual
activism because the whole reason our
socioeconomic and geopolitical systems
are so corrupt and so
Askew is because our spiritual systems
are so corrupted and so Askew so our
spiritual perspective has been so
heavily distorted that it has created a
reflection of that Distortion in our
socioeconomic and geopolitical systems
and that's why we're running into the
issue we're running into if we
understood the real nature of reality
then we wouldn't be in the mess that
we're in it's because of our ignorance
it's because of this crisis of
Consciousness that is here on the planet
that everything is so bad you see so I'm
trying to take the knife out of the hand
not put a Band-Aid on the wound I'm a
spiritual activist I'm trying to bring
spiritual principles that are founded
not only in modern science but also in
ancient traditions and fuse them
together so that people can gain a
larger grander understanding of reality
and therefore create better
socioeconomic and geopolitical systems
so
I broadly agree that the political
problems are
religious and spiritual problems
I disagree in that I don't think it's
just a matter of people not possessing a
sufficient knowledge or Consciousness I
suspect that the reason that the world
has fallen as it is is because of
original sin and I think that you're
you're totally right that these
political systems are just filled with
evil but I think it's because the
Christian view is that uh we're governed
by principalities and powers and
spiritual wickedness in high places and
uh the Gnostic view is this view that
there's the secret knowledge that if we
just get the secret knowledge that the
knowledge itself and Consciousness
itself will will change things I take it
you're more of the Gnostic View
that there's a kind of a knowledge and a
Consciousness we have to attain and then
we won't have this evil in the world
anymore yes to a certain extent
so look at it like this
all of the capitals in the United States
state capitals and our nation's capital
are all built on electromagnetic Ley
lines are you familiar with Ley lines
not really no okay so Ley lines in
simple in the simplest terms are like
rivers of electromagnetic energy that
run all around the planet our planet has
an electromagnetic field right so these
Ley lines go and they surround the
planet but they also go all the way down
to the core of the planet because that's
essentially they're all one right now
where it is that these Ley lines come
across the surface of the planet and
where they crisscross each other that's
where all these ancient sacred sites
like pyramids obelisks ancient temples
um even medicine wheels in the Native
American tradition that's where it is
that they have been placed because these
areas are like centers for electric
heightened electromagnetic activity and
there's also the placement for vortexes
that are in these ecosystems and these
vortexes govern the balance of the
ecosystem based on the distribution of
nutrients water Etc minerals Etc now
all of our Capitol Buildings and
Washington DC all of like the capital
the White House the Lincoln Memorial the
Washington Monument all of these things
are built on Ley lines okay the Vatican
built on Ley lines that also has an
obelisk the London Palace built on Ley
lines also has an obelisk okay the
pyramiding Giza the pyramids in China
the pyramids in mesoamerica all built on
electromagnetic Ley lines right now
each of these buildings is riding law
right what is law law is words or code
and that code is dictating our thoughts
and our emotions and therefore our
Behavior based on what we can buy what
we can sell what is legal what is
illegal Etc now if we have a corrupt
globalist oligarchy that has infiltrated
our system to create laws that favor
them then we have essentially a trojan
horse riding bad code
right and very similar to how if you get
a virus in a computer that virus in the
computer can end up changing the code or
the software to where all of the energy
within that uh that cycled through that
computer gets segued over to one portion
of the computer
right and it slows the computer down
dramatically yeah right so if we look at
the Earth like it's a gigantic super
computer of sorts and we see these
globalist uh less than one percenters
infiltrating the system affecting the
code so that all of our hard work all of
our time all of our energy all of our
money goes to feed them and they're less
than one percent their debt-based
currencies they're less there's 150 uh
corporate international entities they're
uh corrupt governments Etc then we begin
to see how it is that similar to a virus
in a computer all of our time energy all
of our work all of our money is going to
feed them these less than one percenters
so it's
the the less than one percenters these
are the globalists
okay
but it's not just the Democrats it's not
just the rep it's Democrats and
Republicans okay absolutely oh yeah it's
a unit party in DC but it's also
important to understand that what we're
talking about here what what's happened
here in America has happened all over
the world in all of the countries that
have a central banking system a
debt-based currency
Okay so
I'm trying to figure out the timeline
here of the obelisks and the Ley lines
and the
nefarious powers
when when did it all go bad were these
institutions ever good were they ever
just or anything like that or was it
always bad when they built the capital
in DC that was already rotten at that
point no in my opinion from my reading
of history when it comes to the oh so
George Washington was a Mason yeah a lot
of our founding fathers were Masons now
what they were attempting to do was to
get away from the attempt to build the
New World Order in Europe
and and have that be brought over here
to America
okay so they were basically given the
finger to the globalist elite at the
time over in Europe the crown and the
Masons that were over there that were
attempting to control all the resources
and all the labor in the known world at
the time but they were Freemasons too
yes but not all Freemasons are bad
okay okay so the founders understood the
power behind money they understood the
power behind the Ley lines they
understood the power Behind law they
understood the power behind the
government's Monopoly on the initiation
of force they also understood the power
behind uh owning and controlling the
resources the labor and the
transportation of those things
right so they were trying to create a
new system something that had never been
done before a Greco-Roman Democratic
Republic a constitutional republic where
the government recognizes God as the
ultimate Authority and that our rights
come from God not from the government
you see so in the process they were
creating a system that allowed human
beings to practice these god-given
freedoms these god-given rights these
unalienable rights without government
interference hence we get the
Constitution the Bill of Rights Etc you
and you don't see that as being just an
extension of of the English tradition
you know that in in England even with a
king they they recognized that God gives
us certain rights that some of these
rights are protected in Traditions and
constitutions like Magna Carta say or
beginning with Magna Carta and then
coming on through the English common law
tradition or uh
I don't know you're saying it's so what
happens in America it's totally
different well it's it's something
that's never been done before but I
really do think that the founders messed
up in some way shape or form because
they did not recognize that the Native
Americans here were more free than any
European could have possibly dreamed of
and so they failed to integrate like the
Iroquois are you familiar with the
Iroquois and their Republic yeah yeah so
they failed to integrate that kind of a
understanding about nature about uh
symbiosis with other nations with other
people with other tribes so the the
Iroquois were cannibals right I mean the
Iroquois it wasn't all like Pocahontas
Avatar stuff yeah yeah well here's the
thing
there's a lot of misinformation out
there regarding Native American
tradition that's just all there is to it
um the Native Americans were the first
to get screwed over by the feds
okay and if the feds are willing to lie
about modern American citizens why
wouldn't they be willing to lie to for
an agenda way back in the day
um now
regardless of those lies let's not throw
out the baby with the bath water here
okay the Native American tradition of
symbiosis with the environment the
understanding of factoring in the
Seventh Generation any time that a the
tribe comes to a Crossroads and asking
ourselves how will this decision affect
Seven Generations from now we don't do
that yeah we don't we don't think seven
months into the future oh I know Seven
Generations exactly
precisely so that's what I'm doing I'm
thinking centuries ahead I'm thinking
Seven Generations ahead and I'm saying
to myself based on where we're at now if
we continue to go down this road where
are we going to be and this kind of
dives into this idea of uh my care for
the environment
because I have a Oneness with nature so
I view nature as an extension of myself
technically nature is an extension of
everybody you know we're we are a piece
of nature I consider myself distinct
from the natural environment I I
consider myself as the Christian view
that the natural environment is here uh
for me that I am a steward of these
things and that I am here to serve God
and I'm distinct from God in that way
though uh to your point on religion
there is such a thing as Sacrament and
there is such a thing as communion so uh
that's an important aspect too but but I
guess the maybe that the difference in
view that we have here is I don't really
think we're all just kind of one you
know I think that we're rather distinct
and individual
well
that's called ego yep
um and I do everything I can to dissolve
that in myself I'm of the belief that
the only way that we can have any sort
of an objective view of reality is if we
dissolve that ego right so when I've had
boundary dissolving experiences either
through meditation through tattooing
through fasting through sexual
abstinence or through psychedelic
experiences I have had this feeling and
this experience of boundary disillusion
this ego death occurs and the objective
reality of interconnectivity is what I'm
served is what God gives to me and it
this is part of the reason why shamanic
practitioners always pray before they do
any of these things why they it is a
part of a ceremony where your the whole
point is to get in touch with God and to
dissolve the ego so that these
transcendental experiences can be had
now
if in what you're saying about like
nature and being separate if I were to
ask you are you your eyeballs you would
say no you're not your eyeballs you're
not your fingernails no you're not your
liver no you're not your brain right
you're all of these things creating a
hole that is greater than the sum of its
parts and crucially I'm Soul as well
right right so physical but also
metaphysical yes absolutely okay so that
metaphysical soul
what is that
that it's this the technical language
would be that the soul is the
substantial form of the body so the body
is matter and as you say it's not it's
not neatly divisible like you'd divide a
catalytic converter from the other parts
of the car it's part of the whole of my
body so you know if you kill me my liver
is not going to do a lot of good at
least right you know after a short
period of time uh the the body is the
matter and the soul is the form and then
the together there they form a
hylomorphic Unity which is myself that's
my conception okay so your body is made
up of energy yeah
uh if you were to break down every piece
of your your being and you just like
okay made out of atoms what are atoms
made up of quarks you know and you keep
breaking it down eventually you just get
to like this quantum foam of energy
right I'll take your word for it okay so
that means that your soul your very
being which is interconnected with the
body is also made up of energy it's made
up of this pure transcendental uh
everything stuff well I guess this would
be another distinction perhaps between
our views of the world I I don't think
that the metaphysical stuff is uh
it can be simplified down to physical
stuff I think they're distinct in the
way that uh a symbol is distinct from
the thing that it symbolizes I think
that you can get all the way down on the
physical level to my body into all the
little molecules and atoms and quarks
and whatever else is there but you're
not going to find the Soul at the
physical level because the soul is
metaphysical and and they're joined
together in a real way but not in a way
that can be reduced to physicality right
right well energy isn't per se physical
energy is metaphysical it is it is
beyond the physical it is something that
transcends physicality because our
bodies are a frequency of energy
manifesting in a physical form right so
the whole reason why I'm bringing that
up is this
if you are not your body
on its own if your body isn't just its
organs right and you are this whole that
is greater than the sum of its parts
then the same forces of creation the
same forces of creation that created
your body also created the Earth they
created the sun they created the entire
galaxy the whole universe right so if
you are not your eyes or your liver or
your fingernails but you are this whole
that is greater than the sum that also
means that
you are the son you are the Earth you
are interconnected to all of these
things on an energetic level and the
whole point of these transcendental
experiences is to dive into that level
where everything is one
and to have the experience of bliss it
is a very real Bliss to have that
experience of bliss as often as possible
what strikes me most about that
explanation is the way that you were
painted by the media and continued to be
painted by the media is that you're a
far right radical extremist and the same
things they say about me
but our views are very very different on
these on these topics and your
description of things
certainly if you'd asked me 10 years ago
I would say this sounds like a far
left-wing person not like a far right
wing person and maybe you don't
have this left label or right label in
your own self-conception anyway but it
is striking to me that this sounds
kind of Live And yet you're out there
for Donald Trump and for the
conservatives and for the Republican
party is that would you describe your
political activism as a right wing even
or no I'm a Centrist
okay I believe that there are things
that the Republicans have that are or
the conservatives have that are right
and that they're just completely off the
wall wrong and it's the same thing with
the libs with the Liberals there's
things where I agree with them but
there's other things where I'm like
that's absolutely ludicrous you're
that's insane what are some of the
examples of for the left or the right
well a good example for the right would
be uh their stance on things like
cannabis and psychedelic therapy
they think that it's the devil and I
think that's absolutely ludicrous I
don't call it the devil though I do say
it's the devil's lettuce yeah yeah
exactly it's the devil's lettuce or you
know it's it's it's you know
somehow related to evil and that's not
the case at all
um but like with the with the Liberals
like okay I they're behind the whole
thing with psychedelic therapy and
cannabis but then they're also for this
idea
[Music]
so but my point is is that there's a lot
of logical fallacies in that argument
just like there's logical fallacies in
the arguments that are on the right as
well you know for example the death
penalty
the conservatives will say that's a
that's a a baby in the womb that's a
life life is sacred don't harm the baby
which I'm all for yeah okay totally
agree with but then at the same time
they will go and say that we need to
kill inmates and we need to somehow give
the government permission to kill its
own citizens I would say that well but
in some cases but but I look and I
understand why but here's the thing
there have been a lot of people on death
row that have been found to be innocent
yeah okay and y'all if all it takes for
the government to to get rid of their
opposition is smear them enough and and
frame them enough to where they end up
being executed as innocent people then
we the very government that we are
saying is untrustworthy we are now
trusting to kill its own citizens
I don't know about you I wouldn't trust
the Biden Administration with the death
penalty I wouldn't trust the Biden
Administration to pay the highway yeah
so so well then why are we trusting them
with the death penalty well I suppose
the the
people who support the death penalty
such as myself or well really just
anyone who supports any system of Law
and Order you you just have to
have some kind of Law and Order I guess
and so if the Civil Authority is
compromised and corrupt and incompetent
and all the things that it is that's a
horrible problem and we need to fix it
but you can't do without
law you know the law being an ordinance
of reason for the common good
by him who has care of the community and
unfortunately this jerk Joe Biden has
scared of the community so now we've got
to deal with that so there are always
going to be those imperfections
nevertheless we still have to enforce
the law but even even if it's being uh
unduly enforced against certain
political enemies and uh political
friends are getting off the hook for
much more heinous crimes as we're seeing
around us today I'm not advocating for
not having Law and Order what I'm saying
is that it is hypocritical for the
conservatives to say that they support
life and that all life is precious and
then at the same no we would say
innocent life okay innocent life okay
vengeance is mine saith the Lord yes but
but also so the Civil Authority
but I'm not saying we shouldn't lock
these people up if they've committed
murder or child rape or whatever but
vengeance is mine saith the Lord because
there there's a difference between
killing somebody and imprisoning them
yeah okay I know that there's a very
large difference between the death
penalty in prison sure I've been to
prison so I know the kind of treatment
that pedophiles and child rapists get in
prison and the death penalties
but in some cases it's it's the death by
a Thousand Cuts because like for example
there was a dude that was in the prison
that I was at where he his crime was
heinous and it was against a child
and
um he had his ass beat
several times on the yard okay and it
came out of nowhere each and every time
and a lot of the time the person that
did it would end up leaving the prison
and then somebody knew would come and
they didn't know his crime until they
found it out and then they wanted to
beat his ass you see what I'm saying so
vengeance is mine saith the Lord he
couldn't leave that prison because
that's one of the only safe places for
him
he's relatively relatively exactly so do
you see what I'm trying to say though
about how like look
if God doesn't take their life then
there's a reason
God can take anybody's life like that
you know right and if you believe in God
then you believe that so there has to be
a reason why God is not taking the life
of these individuals and should the
power that that God has not chosen to
use be given to the government and our
bad judgment especially if there's a
corrupt government that's in place
Saint Paul would say yes but perhaps a
point for a later debate I'm curious
about how people reacted to you in the
prison
interest in curiosity
um some of the minority communities
for a brief time thought that I was
racist because they watched CNN you know
what I mean
um but then all it took was five minutes
of conversing with me and they realized
this guy's not racist at all this guy's
all right I actually kind of like him
you know
so no one tried to beat you up or
anything like that no I was there I I
was at a prison the prison I was at
there was a riot and actually a lot of
the guys that were in the unit that I
was in as I was like looking out the
window they're like chancelly get away
from the window
they see you they might come in here and
pull you out and beat your ass so get
away from the window there's look
there's good people in prison that just
made really bad decisions of course
right but there's also in anybody that's
been in prison will tell you there's
some scumbags there's some dirt bags
there's some not good people and they
deserve to be in prison
how were you treated by the prison
itself we've read all sorts of stories
about January 6th people who who had
pretty difficult treatment solitary
confinement that sort of thing how was
your treatment well
in DC when I was in the DC jail or DC
Gulag that was the first time I ever
experienced racism in my entire life
um and then after I got moved to
Alexandria Virginia I was in solitary
the whole time so 10 and a half months
they said it was for covid and then they
said it was for my protection but the
thing is is that when they transferred
me to other locations they'll put me in
general population
so then that goes right out the window
these reasons go right out the window I
think personally that it was more so
about trying to break my spirit than it
had anything to do with trying to keep
me safe or you know keeping covid at a
minimum or whatever you were in solitary
confinement for ten and a half months
ten and a half months
how did you
keep any of your wits about you and that
seems it seems like torture
um God my shamanic breathing techniques
prayer meditation
um
and
that's pretty much it I mean I
experienced some miraculous things in
solitary
a good example would be so when I was in
Florence Arizona when I first got
arrested they just arrested me based on
misdemeanor charges okay
the misdemeanor charge was like
trespassing yeah you know parading on
Capitol grounds that kind of stuff and
then about a like four or five days in
they slapped me with two felonies and
then the maximum sentence for those two
felonies was 25 years total so the as I
read again I don't know that I should
believe any reporting on you or January
6th but what I read was the felony was
obstructing an official proceeding yes
and then the other one was like
basically rioting okay which they had no
evidence that I was rioting 25 years as
a maximum sentence so like if I and the
judge that I had when I you know pleaded
guilty and and my sentencing I said you
know I thought I was looking at 20 25
years in prison he said if you would
have gone to trial he said you did you
did the smart thing because if you would
have gone to trial you were looking at
something like 20 years so you avoided
trial by pleading guilty yes and
apologizing saying you regretted it well
you know I I don't want to go too much
into that because of the motion you know
um but long story short
the experience that I had after that
those felonies were slapped on me right
I'm freaking out I'm gonna sell I'm
freaking out I'm like what the hell you
know God you know show me you're with me
show me that you're hearing my prayers
you know give me a sign please I have
and I had a Bible in my hand I said I'm
gonna I'm gonna close my eyes and I'm
gonna open this Bible and I'm going to
point to a random verse with my eyes
closed and I need you to speak with me
tell me you're with me tell me that
you're you this is going to be okay so I
close my eyes I opened the Bible I point
to a random verse and the verse was I am
yours and you are mine I have redeemed
you and called you by name oh Jacob
oh yeah and that just rocked my world
because the likelihood the statistical
likelihood if that would happen is so
astronomical that my name would be in it
of all things talking about redeeming me
I'm yours you are mine like whoa and
there was other things like for example
I'd be in my cell in solitary
confinement in Alexandria and I'd be
praying and praying and praying during
the day and like God like
why you know why'd you ask me to go
through this why'd you ask me to do this
like this is so hard you know the media
is lying the government's lying and I
can't do anything about it I can't
defend myself please give me a sign that
you're still with me give me a sign that
not everybody believes this stuff you
know Etc and then that night I would get
letters like a stack of letters and then
I'd read the letters and there'd be
biblical verses in those letters that
correspond with my prayers or there'd be
people that are being like we don't
believe anything in the media we but we
know that what they're saying is a lie
and blah blah blah we're supporting you
we're praying for you all of that stuff
so all so now here's the interesting
part
the letters were dated a week prior to
my prayer so people sent the letters out
a week before I got them so that means
that God had somebody write a letter
a week prior to answer my prayers a week
later that's a notion of Providence
right Divine Providence that is correct
so well that's that's really beautiful
it must have been very encouraging yes
well and then to have Tucker Carlson
release his footage three weeks before
my release and there's it was just
enough time for people to be outraged
about the fact that I was still in
prison and it was also just enough time
to like exonerate me in the court of
public opinion before I was released
you see it coincidentally I was on his
show that night and I didn't know about
it I don't watch cable news I love
Tucker personally but I just don't I
just don't watch cable news and I happen
to be booked on his show and I was
sitting in the green room and I said
what is this the January 6th tapes what
is this and so I remember I was watching
it in in this in the green room as this
is area I said oh a lot of what we were
told about January 6th just wasn't true
the government had withheld a lot of
pretty important information
so
I get all the post-january 6 stuff or at
least I've got now a clearer picture of
a lot of it
but what about the days before you go
there what impelled you to go what did
you hope to accomplish how did you think
January 6 was going to turn out what was
the point
take me through the days and weeks
before well
I had gone to DC on December 12th for
the second Mega Million March and there
were people around the Capitol Building
people around the Supreme Court
everything was fine
everything was peaceful it was all good
you know so I thought that's what we
were going to experience on January 6th
another peaceful demonstration now this
is the other thing this is another
motivation and reason for me going
DC is built on Ley lines
okay
so as a shamanic practitioner and
somebody that understands the power of
the Ley lines as well as somebody that
understands the power of these sacred
buildings etc etc these are sacred sites
essentially
then if there's going to be a million
people or more than a million people in
Washington DC on that day then
it is my duty as a shamanic practitioner
to be there to input with into the grid
system the most high Vibe positive you
know Vibes possible
so you were there
two through your shamanic practice
protect all the people that were showing
up yes and and uh
the planet as a whole because with that
much energy it can become unstable
you know and that's why I say there's a
very good reason why the cops were
escorting me around the building and it
wasn't because they thought I was
dangerous
it is a little weird that they were
walking you in particular around
I can't talk about it you can't talk
about it all right I'm not telling you
like like there's a very good reason why
for both of our parts and it has nothing
to do with being a fed or an actor or
whatever has nothing to do with that has
everything to do with
the reasons I just gave you for being in
DC I don't think you're a fed or an
actor I I I know that was kind of
floating around for a while but having
talked to you now for I don't know 40
minutes or something like that uh yeah I
don't I never really thought that but I
I I don't think that so I well once your
case is resolved I look forward to
hearing the
oh I want to talk about it thanks yeah I
want to talk about it so you go there
for that did you go there because
you supported Trump or you thought the
election was stolen or you
how much did affinity for Trump play a
role in that and and then beyond
protecting people and putting out the
positive vibes
did you did you think there would be
some conclusion to the January 6th stuff
that either he would remain the
president or they would send the ballots
back to the states or what did you have
a vision of what would happen as a
result of it
thank you
yes and no
so
there's a lot of people that were there
because you know Trump asked people to
show up now look I support a lot of what
Trump has said and done I don't agree
with everything that he said and done
um but that doesn't mean that I you know
I'm gonna abandon the man you know what
I mean uh any successful business owner
knows that you don't want to have a room
full of Yes Men
you know so having some sort of a
independent thought and critical
thinking is not a bad thing
I was it wasn't just about Trump okay
and that's what I think a lot of people
don't understand about what happened on
that day
it wasn't just about Trump in the
election
it was about being lied to about JFK for
decades by the government and the media
okay Trump believes the autopsy we now
know he was shot by more than one bullet
for more than one angle do we oh yeah
it's in the autopsy if I'm not mistaken
Trump Declassified JFK's autopsy and it
I mean all you have to do is watch the
video
he got shot by more than one bullet from
more than one angle I remember seeing a
story come out that
the CIA had some
pre-existing relationship with Lee
Harvey Oswald and I remember this kind
of making I didn't look into it too much
so I don't really know anything about
about that but and then they shot Lee
Harvey Oswald and then the guy Jack Ruby
dies in jail okay what the hell okay so
that's part of it it's also part of it
that like
the media and the government have been
caught and lie after lie after lie after
life scandal after scandal after Scandal
and then we get things like
um recent things like uh weapons of mass
destruction lied about weapons of mass
destruction just so we conveyed Iraq and
take the gold and whatever it else was
that was there that we wanted the oil
um well my this was always one of my
criticisms of the war in Iraq was I
thought we didn't get the oil so at the
very least let's get the oil that was I
think Trump made that that point too he
said where was the oil well but the
thing is is that there's soldiers that
have come back from Iraq talking about
how they were forced to guard oil
pipelines soldiers that came back from
Afghanistan talking about how they
regarding poppy fields and is it just a
coincidence that the poppy production
the Opium production in Afghanistan went
up to the 90 of the world's supply of
heroin and opium and then all of a
sudden there's an opioid epidemic in the
United States and how that coincides
with what the British were doing to the
Chinese and doping them up during the
Opium Wars so that they could control
the people okay so like this this these
are techniques that are ages old so like
we're being lied to over and over again
operation Fast and Furious
okay lied to
um Hillary Clinton 33 000 emails okay
Benghazi no justice whatsoever no
consequence okay no consequences corrupt
justice system okay then Trump is
vilified over and over and over again
after the same media apparatus basically
worship him for 30 years and said he's
the greatest dude ever okay pop culture
Media news media right right so there's
all of that
and then there's Russia Russia Russia
Russia and the corruption behind all
that with the intelligence Community
with the doj okay with the media and
then pushing it pushing it only to find
out that it was all lies it was all Bs
and they knew it they knew it okay
and then there's covet and locking
people in their homes and telling them
you are not essential
you are not valuable basically stay at
home you don't need you and then people
lose their homes people lose their cars
their kids are hungry
you see what I'm trying to say and then
there's the riots in 2020 and no justice
there 95 to 90 of the charges filed
against those Riders were dropped now
you look at the numbers even just
Manhattan in the Bronx vast majority of
these people get off maybe a slap on the
wrist maybe not even a slap on the wrist
yeah yeah so okay so you've got this
sense of Injustice at not just one
politician or support for one politician
but this notion that the established
power the liberal establishment call it
the the regime the uni party the uni
party is deeply corrupt
and so you support Trump then because
what Trump is just a wrench in the
system
I support Trump because some of the
things that he did in particular trying
to end child to human trafficking that's
the modern day slave trade
okay and there are more slaves now in
the world than there ever has been in
history and I think everybody can be
against human slavery okay so why are we
not trying to fight it why did Biden
rescind that executive order one of the
first things he did about you know
basically not making a child in human
trafficking a priority for the doj why
are they taking people that are on
terrorism cases child molestation
molestation cases murder cases
um drug trafficking cases why are they
taking them off those cases at the FBI
and putting them on misdemeanor cases
for January 6. why okay and then so for
me it's like okay what would evidence of
government corruption look like
right 10 for the big guy you know Wars
in Ukraine wars in Afghanistan Wars in
Iraq
um the Iran Contra Scandal bringing
cocaine into the country you know uh
the list goes on and on and on the
Franklin cover-up with um uh Lawrence
King are you familiar with that where
they were basically raping kids and
trafficking drugs and doing Satanic
rituals in Nebraska Lawrence King oh
yeah the Franklin cover-up but John
DeCamp wrote a book about it and it
didn't how it involves Satanism and
stuff like that okay and so this is what
I do believe that I don't know about
this particular case or anything like
that but I've I've
read enough cases and heard enough
credible stories from authorities to
acknowledge there is a uh clearly an
occult aspect to
some of these crimes that it's not just
sex crimes or drug crimes or whatever
but there is an occult aspect to to at
least a number of them yeah I'm
convinced of that so you're seeing all
of this now is this
Q Anon I don't know what Q Anon is I all
I know about Q Anon is they say you're a
q Anon person and they say that q anon's
a right-wing thing and the only time I
ever hear about it is on CNN okay so
let's make a very clear distinction
between Q and The Q posts or the Q drops
and Q Anon and the Q Anon Community
Jacob I don't know what any of these
things are okay so
let's break this down
Q is a psychological operation
okay okay
now
psychological operations are largely
based on three factors number one is
neuro-linguistic programming that is the
use of certain uh words Linguistics to
program the neurons or the pattern of
neurons in the brain in particular the
subconscious portion of the brain to
affect the way that a person consciously
perceives reality
okay
number two you have something called
critical Factor bypass critical Factor
bypass is where you saturate the
entirety of the environment in the Media
newspapers magazines television shows in
the corporate world in banking you name
it in schools colleges you saturate all
of them with a very specific message and
you repeat it over and over and over and
over again
okay now what happens then is that the
subconscious mind because it sees it
everywhere it assumes that it must be
true that this has to be real because
it's everywhere in the environment so it
programs once again the subconscious
mind of effect the way the conscious
mind perceives reality now based on
neuro-linguistically programming the
individual and mass neuro-linguistically
programming the populations through
critical Factor bypass why they call it
that is because your critical thinking
is bypassed because this program is
subconscious brain
that creates something called Mass
formation hypnosis
okay we're 25 to 30 percent of the
population believes this external
stimuli believes and is programmed by
this material they're just sheep Sheeple
Sheeple okay okay
so
in order for Mass formation hypnosis to
occur that 25 to 35 about 25 to 30
percent of the population has to gain
some sort of heightened level of
radicalism where they scream the loudest
and then they get a hold of the levers
of power
right now
when it comes down to
stopping this process from happening all
you need is five percent or more of the
population to not become hypnotized
and say no this is ludicrous you are
nuts we are not doing that now we've
seen the effects of mass formation
hypnosis critical Factor bypass and
neuro-linguistic programming in Nazi
Germany we saw it with the Bolshevik
Revolution in Russia and the USSR we saw
in the Red Revolution in China in the
Chinese Communist Party Okay so we've
seen the effects of this process and it
is psychological warfare okay
now when it comes to Q and The Q
operation and the reason I say it's a
psychological operation is this this is
how it differs
the operation Mockingbird media what I
call the Mockingbird media operation
Mockingbird CIA infiltrating the media
outlets right so the Mockingbird media
uses the techniques I just laid out to
program the populations so that they can
use this propaganda to go to war
and then they can transfer public money
into private hands
you see so it's it's it's a whole scheme
it's all about maintaining the status
quo now Q
is on the internet it first started on
4chan then on 8coon and when I was
looking at it from an uh objective
perspective what I saw was that Q was
asking people questions not giving them
answers what does the Mockingbird media
do this is what happens this is what it
means giving people answers
neuro-linguistically programming people
how do you dissolve neuro-linguistic
programming how do you dissolve
subconscious programming you ask
questions
isn't that convenient though because if
you're asking questions you can never be
proven wrong right if I make a
prediction
and I say so and so is going to win the
election and then so and so doesn't win
the election then I look like I don't
know what I'm talking about but if if
someone calling himself Q just asks
questions then he can always sort of
seem like he's right
or something right you know Nostradamus
writes in these riddles and so now in
later on we can look back in hindsight
and say oh well he was really predicting
this event or that event but maybe it
was maybe he wasn't he was speaking in
such an ambiguous way that that his
predictions could refer to almost
anything right but that's the objection
yeah I understand what you're saying and
you're right to a certain extent however
this is how I came to these conclusions
that this is a psychological operation
by the highest levels of military
intelligence and the intelligence
community that cue itself so Q is this
person who's posting I don't think it's
a person I think it's a group so it's a
q is a group that's posting questions on
fora like 4chan or the Southern acun and
uh you're saying that that is an is a
psyop
from the highest levels of government or
or I would say most likely highest
levels of the military okay because
Military Intelligence in the
intelligence Community tend to work
together sure
um now what led me to that conclusion is
the numerical code in the queue drops to
themselves
and the Gap code between the time that
Trump would tweet something and Q would
do a q drop
and what is called the Q clock okay so
if you look into cryptology and
encrypting information then you will see
that what the Q drops were doing was
very very similar to the way Military
Intelligence communicates and this is
how it is that you're able to
communicate a message in plain sight
without the enemy knowing what exactly
it is that you're saying because it's
all encrypted it's all encoded now the
numerical code if you look at the
numerical code and then you line that up
with certain other and you learn the
numerical code you can line it up in a
way where these numer these numbers end
up creating a much larger message and
it's the same thing with the Q clock the
Q clock is like a regular clock with 12
numbers right but above each of the
numbers are dates
and each of these dates are different
now
when you align all of these dates
together and then you get all the cue
drops that were on that day then it
creates a much larger message that is
very interconnected with each other but
each of these dates each of these drops
is on a different day
so it's about spreading out this much
larger message that when you put it
together put the puzzle together
properly
the message becomes clear so it's
equivalent to Military Intelligence
dumping a massive puzzle on the table of
the internet and saying figure it out
why are they doing this so that's a
great question
how do you dissolve massive Mass
formation hypnosis you have to get at
least five percent or more of the
population to reject the the programming
the hypnosis The Narrative right how you
get people to denuri linguistically
program themselves you ask them
questions and then they do their own
research
right and then they come to the
conclusions on their own you can't just
tell somebody the government's corrupt
you have to show them and you know who
Yuri besmanov is yes okay this is the
Soviet guy yes and he was a KGB
operative in charge of psychological
warfare what they called ideological
subversion right so think about this
Yuri besanov said that the Soviets and
the global communist conspiracy which he
said is very real okay and he would know
they infiltrate countries in particular
uh he was talking about the United
States but all countries through a
ideological Warfare campaign a
psychological Warfare campaign that is
broken down into four parts
demoralization which takes a full
generation infiltrate the entertainment
infiltrate the schools the colleges
infiltrate governments infiltrate the
media Outlets Etc okay then indoctrinate
or demoralize a whole generation of
children
then after that you get destabilization
now what ends up happening there is that
once that whole generation has been
demoralized then you use the
infiltrators that did the demoralization
in conjunction with the demoralized
generation
and then they destabilize the system and
that takes a couple of years then once
the system has been destabilized that's
when you get into the third part crisis
so then this collapse of the supply
chain the failing of banks
um the uh the housing market crash etc
etc these are the crisis that occur
right then the last part is
normalization and what happens is that
during the crisis portion these
infiltrators that did the demoralization
destabilization they move into positions
of power high level positions of power
then they normalize all of this stuff
and they create a communist government
okay
so so how does this relate to Q yeah
right
how this relates to Q is this there are
entities within our government within
what some people call the Deep State
okay the bureaucracy the intelligence
apparatus military intelligence that do
not want to see the United States of
America fall they do not want a new
world order one world government they do
not want these less than one percenters
dictating our lives and the lives of our
children
so the Q operation was done so that
this demoralized population which Yuri
besanov said you could show people in
black and white the truth and they won't
believe it because they're so heavily
demoralized you could take them to the
concentration camps and they will not
believe it until they're behind the
Gates
right how do you deprogram people you
give them questions they do their own
research they come to their own
conclusions and they see the government
corruption on their own they see the
fences
they see the gates and they realize the
system then what they have been told is
for their security is actually for their
enslavement or their imprisonment and
all it takes is five percent
right so we have in the United States
far more than five percent who can see
through the BS yeah certainly I mean if
if you're defining that as people who
know that the media and the government
lie to us all the time I was probably
like 65 and it seems like a lot of
people yeah and that's been true for a
while I think so
so why do we need Q well what are the
things and this is also important to
understand about psychological warfare
operations or psychological operations
the the three main things that Q was
talking about and that that I think are
the most important are the fiat
debt-based currency and the FED okay
number two the child trafficking human
trafficking networks the slave trade
right number three the government
corruption and how it's rooted in these
things and how the government is using
his Monopoly on the initiation of force
to enforce this new world order one
world government and subjugate anybody
that's gonna dissent right that's in my
opinion right now
infiltration instead of invasion
according to JFK that's what we're
talking about here right infiltration
instead of invasion so if the entities
that are running the global governments
the banks the child trafficking networks
using them to Blackmail people through
like you know Jeffrey Epstein and stuff
like that control governments Etc
if these individuals are doing all of
that
then how is it that you're going to
convince enough of the population that
this thing is actually happening they're
going to have to look into it themselves
and find all the dirt themselves right
but that's
that's not
look at it like this if those people
that are trying to keep all this hidden
are trying to stop qanna or trying to
stop Q from doing this what are they
going to do they're going to create a
straw man cue Anon a right-wing
conspiracy theory right that believe
that there's reptilian overlords
governing the the world and all this
other stuff they're then they're going
to also infiltrate like and say JFK Jr
is alive and he's Donald Trump's vice
president I saw something about the JFK
Jr has something to do with Q Anon yeah
but he doesn't well this or the Earth is
flat okay so what this is about is these
very real concepts of debt-based
currency child trafficking government
collusion and blackmail and all that
stuff they become then contaminated by
JFK Jr Flat Earth reptilian overlords
and then so anybody that believes this
other stuff now gets painted as a kook
because the media shines the light on
that portion of the population that's
infiltrated so and you're saying even
the term Q Anon is a that's interesting
okay so then how would you how would you
describe your views you say I'm not part
of Q Anon
well the media gave me q and on Shaman
they did Alex Jones he's the one that
called me Q Shaman then the media called
me the Q Anon Shaman and then ever and
then they started saying I call myself
that
that never happened
so it never happened so I okay I'm
getting a clearer picture of this now
your your claims are much more modest
and I guess the Q people whatever that
they would call themselves their claims
are more modest than what I've seen in
the headlines or CNN says they believe
JFK Jr is still alive and whatever else
and you're saying no we just think that
the political order is very corrupt and
people are blackmailing each other and
there is uh unaccountable Power and
there's some weird creepy sex stuff
obviously you see Jeffrey Epstein you
know that's that's before our very eyes
Okay so fine now I see that this is a
much more modest claim than the CNN
people tell me but then what is the
claim I mean who are these guys is it
the Illuminati is it the the the lizard
people is it the CIA is it the Soviet
Communists and Yuri Yuri best manov who
what is this
okay so what we're talking about is
something that stretches back all the
way into Antiquity okay the Canaanite
sacrifices uh to ball or Malik of
children of men and women virgins
um the Babylonians and their black magic
um it goes all the way back to things
like Sumer
okay uh and every Empire Sumer Babylon
um Egypt
Persia
Greece Rome and currently you know the
the English the English Empire for a
while and now what's going on in America
all of them have practiced three things
in particular to control people number
one is what's called money magic
okay the use of a currency to control
the population's minds so if I convince
you that this this little coin this this
this uh gold coin is more valuable than
this fish
I have to use some form of like a spell
to convince you because you can't eat
the gold coin but you can eat the fish
you see what I'm saying true but I I
could rationally
deduce that a monetary system will make
it easier for me to trade goods and
services well yes but but the point is
is that if that if that monetary system
is owned by a certain person then they
control everybody okay if it is based in
debt then they control everybody and the
whole notion of the currency having
value is an illusion
do you see what I'm trying to say so
that's why I say money magic okay okay
because it's based on an illusion and
it's based on a generally agreed upon
illusion right when in all reality the
materials the resources the water the
food those are what's really valuable
and the money just symbolizes that yes
okay
the next thing is human slavery okay so
they have money magic then they have
human slavery that they use to objectify
the individual okay and a lot of the
time it's the people that own the
currency that have the slaves or the
people that have the most of the
currency that have the slaves right now
in our case we are debt slaves yes but
there's more slaves now than there ever
has been in human history
human and child trafficking that's a
modern day slave trade right so that
apparatus is being used to control the
world because a lot of the same people
that are involved in the child and human
trafficking trade are also a part of
these child sex trafficking rings that
are being used by these people that own
the monetary system to control
governments like with Jeffrey Epstein
okay does that make sense to some degree
the the thing that keeps going back and
forth though is on the one hand there
are these kind of Moda what seemed to me
relatively modest claims about the
corruption of governments and then on
the other hand
this more Fantastical kind of Claim
about uh
like moloch worshiping well have you
seen what's going on in Bohemian Grove
no you haven't looked at Bohemian girl I
think I might maybe I saw a video where
they're worshiping the owl garden I did
see that yeah The Cremation of care and
I mean dude Nixon was there uh Reagan
was there Kissinger was there Ford was
there I saw I saw this video and it was
it is really freaky and bizarre and but
didn't they or apologists for this group
didn't they say oh it's just a kind of a
joke it's kind of a show it's like
summer camp you know you do a little
it's like a play basically you know I
don't know no no no no
um here's the thing I looked into that
okay
there's the test there's testimony of a
guy named Zachary King who is an
ex-satanic wizard okay and Warlock
and this guy talked about how he did
Satanic rituals for the people in
Bohemian Grove okay he also said he did
him inside of abortion clinics but
people well doctors these satanic
doctors are doing abortions and
literally basically giving the child
soul to Satan no you can look it up I
believe that no no another testimony
there's a kid named a guy now he's a man
but at the time a kid named Paul Bonacci
that was trafficked by Lawrence King the
Nebraska Franklin cover-up he was also
uh he was also trafficked um according
to him in a location where there were
massive trees
Bohemian Grove is
in the Redwoods
okay and the stuff that he talked about
that he was forced to participate in
is unspeakable like you probably
couldn't air it but it's in my book one
mind at a time a deep state of Illusion
by Jacob Angeli if you want to check it
out it's on Amazon it's only 9.99 but
the point is is that his testimony and
the stuff that was going on in there is
so bad it's so unspeakable now how does
this relate to this idea of a cult right
and how and and the third portion of the
three that you got the money magic
you've got the slavery and then you've
got human and child sacrifice this is
what has kept Humanity in line for a
long time and it has to do with the Ley
lines okay so a lot of these rituals
that were being done these murder
rituals and stuff like that human child
sacrifice were being done in temples or
in locations that were built on the Ley
lines and then so that really low
frequency fear-based emotions and
thoughts are being plugged into the grid
system of the planet
you see and those affect our minds
especially when it's done in public like
it was because then everybody would
worry and wonder is the king gonna
choose my child is the king gonna choose
my daughter she's a virgin you know what
I mean am I going to be a slave all it
takes is the king pointing at me and
saying that man is my slave now
you see what I'm saying so it's about
controlling once again the collective
consciousness of humanity
okay it's about subversion and control
it's about
um enslavement of the mind and the body
but first it has to be the mind
now this is where we get into something
called Full Spectrum dominance if you're
familiar with that term no it's a
military term
so full spectrum dominance means control
in particular of the Mind psychological
warfare
and therefore from the mind you get
control of the land the sea the air and
the airspace the Subterranean deep
underground military bases
extraterrestrial or space satellites
chemical and biological agents and
Technology cell phones computers
televisions cell phone towers radio Etc
and so these less than one percenters
realize that they could not be God right
but what they could do and when you say
the less than one percentage you're
saying it's not just some Modern group
you're saying it's the same group that
goes back to ancient Sumer or it's just
yes it goes back to just after the
Garden of Eden same familial lineages
and it's and and it when you when you
refer to this you're saying this is just
like a cult or yes well but see the
thing is that occult just means hidden
from View
or unseen okay okay and it's reference
to so when I'm asking you to maybe this
that explains it because what I'm asking
you to say okay but who is it it's the
CIA it's the Illuminati what is it
you're saying no by definition the group
has to be hidden from view well by
definition occult just means hidden from
View and these same entities have been
doing this for centuries for Millennia
okay and it is based on the same
familial lineages for example
um the royal family in England is uh
connected to a bunch of royal families
in Europe and they're all descendants or
they all have relations to Vlad the
Impaler
Dracula okay now another example
would be how it is that these families
when their Empires collapse say in Sumer
then they move to other places like
Babylon or then they moved to Egypt or
then they moved you know to to Persia or
then Greece and then et cetera et cetera
the whole point here is is that it's the
same familial lineages and it's the same
DNA okay and they breed within their
families they breed within this very
tightly knit group because this tightly
knit group is the ones practicing these
rituals and they've been doing it for
thousands of years and when they get
initiated into these levels of the
occult which occult means hidden from
you it's it's like an interdimensional
thing it's like a practicing of evil
witchcraft black magic
okay now coming back to uh what I was
saying before about
the controlling of the mind and the
populations
the
full spectrum dominance uh aspect of
that of all this is this these less than
one percenters knew they could not be
God
but they could play God within a system
in which they have full spectrum
dominance you see because then they
control all of the water all of the food
all of the air they control all the
resources they control all the labor
they control the financial system
etc etc now the only way they can do
that is by controlling our minds first
this is why we're seeing so much
censorship
[Music]
thank you
it's part of the reason why we're seeing
the financial collapses and the mass
pollutions like the explosion at the
chemical plant in in Louisiana or the
thing in East Palestine Ohio and stuff
like that it's about gaining Farmland
it's about full spectrum dominance okay
and I had some there was a guy on Spaces
the other day that was saying that a lot
of these trained derailments are just so
happened they just so happen to be owned
uh or done by somebody the I think it's
a corporation that Bill Gates has a
large stock in and then they end up
contaminating Farmland that Bill Gates
wants to own you see so once again full
spectrum dominance it's about the food
you see so presumably he wouldn't want
to poison his own land no it's not about
poisoning the land what it's about is
getting the farmers off of it okay and
then buying it up real cheap at least
that's what this guy on Spaces was
saying I'm not saying I haven't done the
research the point I'm making though is
that there are very real
strategies for doing this for gaining
and keeping and maintaining full
spectrum dominance now the only way to
defeat it
is for us to awaken this is why I say we
have a crisis of consciousness
but so if you're saying though that
there has been this problem this sort of
evil group of people for all of human
history and they're expressed in the
royal families and you know they're part
of it and all of these
groups that going back to ancient
Babylon or wherever uh
if this has always been a problem then
why now why is now the cue moment what
to me if if you said well there's always
been this corruption in the political
order I'd say yeah there's probably
always going to be that corruption until
you know the good Lord comes back again
but until that time that's how it's
going to go
why not why show up now and
try to
retake the civilization
so are you familiar with the the age of
Aquarius no I know it's from a song well
no it's it's it's this is the dawning
and everything yes yes that's from like
like hair hair right yeah
well they are referencing something far
more ancient okay what we're talking
about is What's called the procession of
the equinox and it's when the uh
constellations align with the Rising Sun
on the equinoxes okay
and every 2160 years I believe is a new
age
okay we're a new constellation aligns
with the Rising Sun during the equinox
we just came out of the age of Pisces
okay you're a Pisces okay my age is gone
okay that's we're past what now the age
of Pisces Fish and water
right and we're in the age of Aquarius
which is the people pouring the water
Okay so
it's almost like the now this is
important I'll get back to this whole
idea of Pisces and Age of Aquarius
we also just completed a like 25 or 26
000 year cycle where we went through the
whole zodiac
okay we completed that whole cycle okay
we are also completing what is called
the Kali Yuga which is like a 4 432
000 year cycle of a bunch of these 25
000 year Cycles okay so remember how I
was saying earlier about like these
cycles of energy from higher Dimensions
to lower dimensions and and all that
stuff okay
so what this is about is the dispensing
of energy in larger volumes
here not just in our galaxy but in the
universe from the universe to the Galaxy
and the Galaxy to all the stars in the
galaxy including ours and our planet all
the way down to our bodies and we're
channeling this energy through our DNA
through this feedback loop with the
energetic unified field all right now as
the Kali Yuga ends as this 25 000 year
cycle we just went through ends we're
coming into What's called the Golden Age
where this knowledge that has been
hidden occult this knowledge that has
been hidden for so long now is revealed
the apocalypse just means lifting the
veil or revealing the unseen lifting the
veil during a time of mass deception so
are we in the apocalypse we are in the
apocalypse and it's not a bad thing
think about it
right now
it's not that the world is getting worse
because it's always been this bad what
it is is that the evidence of global
corruption or government corruption is
becoming so obvious
that it's blowing people's minds and
they don't know how to handle it because
they're having a cognitive dissonance
their mind is being changed so the
apocalypse while it is something that
happens in the world it is largely
something that happens in the mind
because now you're seeing the reality
you're seeing the objective reality and
this is why I practice Shamanism because
I've been seeing this reality for over
10 years so
people say that you showed up in the
horn hat to these political rallies and
then the apotheosis of that is January
6th at the Capitol because you're a
revolutionary but you're saying no no no
I'm not a revolutionary I'm heralding
the apocalypse forget about a political
revolution we're talking about the end
of time we're talking about the a new
age and I am a evolutionary
I'm going to use that I I'm an
evolutionary not a revolution I want to
evolve as an individual and as a society
so then Ultra is a Race So then what
happens at every level individual
political social and Cosmic we're
entering this new age we're in the
apocalypse energies everywhere what does
that look like at all three of those
levels
okay so are you familiar with cymatics
no okay now I'm going to answer your
question so cymatics is I'm sure you've
seen those those videos where they have
like grains of rice or sand on like a
plate or a speaker and then they they
hit it with sound and then the pattern
changes yeah okay that's cymatics okay
and you can do the same thing with water
molecules Etc
so the higher the frequency then the
more complex the pattern and a lot of
the time when the frequency changes from
say a lower frequency to a higher
frequency there's a very brief period of
time in between the transition where
there is no pattern everything is all
chaotic and then all of a sudden boom a
new pattern snaps into place right
so what we're going through right now
from about the 1960s to about 20 40.
okay is this apocalypse is this
transition that is going to take place
where the the chaos there's no
recognizable pattern because the
frequency of the universe itself is
transitioning from a lower frequency to
a higher frequency okay and if you want
to look at it like this
human beings are the grains of rice
the Earth is the speaker
and the electromagnetic field around the
earth is the frequency
and so we're being moved our thoughts
which are interconnected to the
electromagnetic spectrum of the planet
our bodies interconnected to the
electromagnetic field of the planet our
emotions are connected to the
electromagnetic field of the planet all
of these things are going to change okay
so I I like this image as a as a symbol
of History because history doesn't just
move in a way where one day changes and
the next day is a little bit different
and that goes on at infinitum but no
there are ages of history as you
describe and so there can be major
cataclysmic changes and then you get the
beads of rice all shaken up and then a
new world order emerges so I kind of
like that image
but now what is that going to look like
individual political Cosmic okay so
because our thoughts are going to change
because our emotions are going to change
our view of reality is going to change
and that also means and this is so I've
seen uh as I've had shamanic visions of
the future okay I knew Barack Obama was
going to be president in 2004. and you
can ask my family I was telling
everybody is it just because he gave
that impressive speech no no no no no no
dude I'm talking like a shamanic Vision
I knew that he was going to be president
I knew he was going to create a
caliphate in the Middle East with 10
countries 10 Islamic countries you can I
mean you know as my brother
okay
I'm telling you so I've seen these
Visions I've seen things
all right there's two realities that we
can choose
one is the transhumanist reality where
we surrender our god-given rights to
these globalists and we create a race of
synthetic humans based on cloning and
geoengineering and stuff like that the
planet itself the the pollutants don't
stop they just keep on spreading and
spreading and spreading they
bioaccumulate in the system in the in
the ecosystem they destroy the water and
the air they destroy the soil they
destroy the food and then eventually we
have a borg hive mind of AI controlled
synthetic human beings living on a
radioactive Rock
all right and we don't have a Seventh
Generation and the earth goes extinct
okay that's one route the other route is
we awaken we
more than this five percent that say no
to the mass formation hypnosis say no
we're not doing this we Are Spiritual
Beings we are connected to God we have
god-given rights you don't get to tell
us what to do this is our planet and you
sir do not get to tell us how to live on
it right and when we do that we will
have organic Humanity spiritually Ascent
where we get into higher levels of
frequency regarding our thoughts and our
emotions these higher levels of
frequency mean more information is going
to be channeled through our bodies
through our DNA with God and God
Consciousness non-local Consciousness
now what is that going to what is that
massive transformation going to manifest
as far as Global socioeconomics and
geopolitics
Nikola Tesla in the early 1900s invented
an infinite free clean wireless tower
for Distributing energy and was built on
the electromagnetic Ley lines and it
amplifies the positive and negative
charge on these electromagnetic Ley
lines to a certain radius around the
tower that gives people infinite free
clean wireless electricity
okay so sign me up where do I plug in
dude that's the question now why don't
people know about this because JP Morgan
The Rockefellers you know all of the big
bankers at the time suppress this
technology because they wanted to make
money off of charging people for
electricity they wanted to make money
off of oil
you see what I'm saying they wanted to
make money off of owning and controlling
full spectrum dominance all of the
resources and all the labor in the
country and in on the planet Nikola
Tesla's invention is the antithesis of
that so what we'll see is we're going to
see Tesla Towers pop up all over the
place
and we're going to see War become
obsolete because all of our Wars are
over resources so if we make resources
infinite Wars obsolete you don't think
people have wars over
ideas and culture
in addition to resources the motivation
behind all wars are about owning the
land and controlling the people and the
resources whether it be gold water food
whatever okay you know but like a holy
war I understand what you're saying but
but
The Holy War is Over what the land
I don't know I think it might be over
the religion maybe not call me nice but
what I'm saying is that the religion is
the excuse for the procuring of the land
just like you know weapons of mass
destruction was the excuse for going in
Iraq but I guess the reason I'm pausing
there is the
your explanation of it is a materialist
explanation that our our highfalutin
ideas about religion and culture and
ideology that's really all a facade to
cover up core material interests like
oil and money and land and the rest hold
so so I hear you saying that
at one moment but then at another moment
you're speaking in a way that seems
quite immaterial quite divorced from
just money and stuff and you're talking
about vibrations and ideas and God and
and all these these metaphysical things
and and so I'm wondering if there's not
a contradiction there well no there's
not and I'll explain why um as I unfold
in this process of explaining about
Tesla towers and how it is that that's
going to transform our Consciousness and
then must speak to this idea of
religious Holy Wars
so
most wars I would say all wars are
fought over the con over the resources
or the land
so if we make resources infinite War
becomes obsolete we also would make all
pollution obsolete because now we have
an infinite free clean Wireless form of
electricity we don't need a drill for
oil we don't need natural gas we don't
need solar panels polluting the
environment with their 50 toxic
chemicals we don't need wind turbines
killing birds and we certainly don't
need lithium mining or Cobalt mining
which all destroy the environment
exponentially and they create what are
called anthropogenic chemicals or
forever chemicals that pollute the
ecosystem to the point to where they
become toxic because of something called
bioaccumulation that bioaccumulation of
these anthropogenic chemicals which do
not biodegrade ends up killing off all
the microbiological life in the soil and
in the water
okay in order for life to exist there
has to be microbiological life in the
soil and in the water otherwise we don't
grow food and there is no fish right so
pollution becomes obsolete because we
have an infinite free clean wireless
energy also the control over all of our
communication Towers the cell phones the
satellites cell phone towers computers
internet Wi-Fi all that goes out the
window because now these Tesla Towers
can be used to communicate on a global
scale and we don't have to use the
globalist owned centralized grid system
and if you look into Erickson and the
Erickson report and the way that they
have been responsible for transmitting
all the communication in the world and
how that stems back to like even the
transmission of child pornography
military Communications and things of
that nature how they're responsible for
like telling Al Qaeda and Isis like
where uh soldiers American soldiers were
and how that led to the death of
American soldiers then you can really
see the danger behind centralizing our
communication grid who who did this the
company Ericsson you haven't heard about
the Ericsson report no look into it
Ericsson
uh I would say 93 of the time you say
have you heard about the answer is going
to be no I do very minimal you know
research on on these sorts of things so
Erickson is a company International
Communications telecommunications
corporation okay and
you and you're saying they told Isis
where American soldiers are if I'm not
mistaken that's what the report says
okay okay
so
and they're also responsible from what
the report says that for responsible for
the child pornography that's all around
the planet
because they are transmitting and they
know about it at least that's what the
report says according to what it what it
is that I now I'm I'm disoriented
because we're zooming in and zooming out
yeah I'm sorry no but I don't apologize
I'm just trying to get a handle on it
and this is this is part of the cue
thing or this is just your own personal
no dude that look Q is a very small part
of my story yeah the media tried to make
it a big one because then that's how
they could create a straw man that they
could then smear yeah me and divide the
country yeah yeah when these ideas are
very unifying you know you said sign me
up infinite free clean wireless
electricity sign me up right everybody
can feel that way
Republican and Democrat voters alike so
it will give us
infinite free clean wireless electricity
new forms of community a new form of
communication and be and both of these
together is going to create economic
surplus right
um it will make war Obsolete and it can
also allow us to purify the environment
so we can get rid of the bioengineering
uh stratospheric aerosol injections and
all of the soft metals and barium and
aluminum stuff in the atmosphere we can
also use it to um help plants grow so
agriculture can be like through the roof
because you can use these frequencies to
help plants to grow like like that okay
you can also use it to neutralize uh
pollution through combining these
frequencies with bioremediation and
fungus that eat radioactive material or
eat contaminated soil with like diesel
fuel and stuff like that okay what I'm
talking about is is a real ecological
Evolution a real agricultural Evolution
a energetic Evolution and so the
evolution of our minds is going to
manifest as an evolution in
technological innovation and as regards
to medicine as well Dr Rife that's Riffe
Royal Raymond Rife in the 1930s he was
working with Nikola Tesla on creating a
machine that could destroy disease and
viruses and cancer cells and all that
stuff
with sound and frequency the way you can
destroy a wine glass with sound and
frequency yeah you can destroy disease
with sound and frequency this machine
was suppressed The Rockefellers who own
big Pharma in the modern pharmaceutical
industry and in the medical industry
they suppressed it they they just look
into Tesla in his story and look into Dr
Rife and his story and what you're going
to find are three things number one
government corruption at its Inception
here in the United States in the early
1900s number two you're going to find
all of the all of the uses for the
devices that these men made how it could
transform agriculture transform
Communications transform energy
transform weather manipulation and and
purifying ecosystems how it could uh
change our entire global grid system and
then lastly and this is the most
important part
and this this kind of comes back to this
idea of brand Bridging the physical and
the metaphysical like what you were
talking about okay
Nikola Tesla said if you want to
understand the secrets of the universe
think in terms of energy frequency and
vibration
okay
in order to understand how Tesla towers
work in order to understand how Dr Rife
and his Machine Works to cure disease
you have to know and understand energy
frequency and vibration
so as people research this stuff not
only do they uncover government
corruption not only do they see the
tools that we could use to free
ourselves forever and purify the planet
but they also see the secrets of the
universe and they unfold before people
and the bridging between the physical
and the metaphysical how these things
come together and how ideologies that
are based on
separation
are also rooted in parasitism and
genocide
say more about that that last part that
ideology rooted in separation
is
has to do with parasitism and genocide
what does that mean look at it like this
so in the Amazon their definition of
evil is the idea of investing in this
idea of being separate
from another person from the environment
Etc that that's where evil comes from
now if you look into the work of Philip
zimbardo the guy that did the Stanford
Prison Experiment
oh dude you gotta look into it so Philip
zimbardo he did the Stanford Prison
Experiment were basically discovered
that
um
even if it's just college students doing
a drill or a a play role of your guard
your inmate there becomes this divide
where the guards become abusive and
authoritarian and the inmates become
combative and revolutionary because of
this dynamic because of these roles
right opposing yes interests and roles
yes
so he also went on he was like I think
he was like a psychologist
um or a psychiatrist he went on to
investigate the origins of evil in the
psychology of evil he did a lecture
called the Lucifer effect and the
psychology of evil and what he came to
find was that there are three main
things really that cause human beings to
do evil things number one
dehumanization either of a person or a
group yeah so the other
separation
right go ahead hold on haven't you done
that with these the these ancient
peoples who are expressed through the
British royal family and the
Rockefellers and the you know all the
terrible because I don't advocate for
their death but you're separating them
no no you're saying they're responsible
for all the problems no it's it's
similar to identifying the root cause
I'm not I'm not saying they're the other
there's a lot of people that want these
people's heads and I've said in a lot of
spaces on Twitter that like no no no no
no no that's not the solution that's not
a solution at all the solution is if God
hasn't taken these people's lives we
shouldn't either we need to we need to
yes create and we need to stop this but
the only way to stop what they're doing
which it what they're doing is based on
separation and because of their belief
of Separation they have created a system
that is parasitic on the environment and
parasitic on human beings and in the
process they've created mass extinctions
of plant species of animal species
genocide and foreign Nations
displacement of whole populations you
know the tri the human trafficking trade
child sex trafficking all of these
things are based on this illusion of
separation
okay so I look at them and I say well
technically they're a part of this
unified whole
okay and what I'm advocating for is not
the destruction of the old system
but making the old system obsolete by
creating a new one
and you do that through helping people
to understand what happened why it
happened where it happened when it
happened and how we can do something so
much better so much more quickly that
seriously within a couple of months to a
couple of years we would see a whole new
planet A Whole New World so your vision
sounds to me like
a very optimistic utopian some might say
vision of of Heaven on Earth yes oh it
is going to be Heaven on Earth yeah this
is the apocalypse we're we're going to
be we're alive during the most exciting
time in human history this is the time
that all the Ancients pointed to and
said I want to be alive right there I
want to see what happens there
what if we're not
I I say this because you know in the
Bible Christ says nobody knows the day
or the hour not even the son only the
father nobody nobody knows a lot of
people throughout history have thought
they were living in the end times and
they weren't
so what if we're not
well Christ also said
um
many people throughout history have
longed to see and hear what you have
seen and heard and not have and have not
seen and heard it yeah yes so he
announced obviously
I say this as a Christian
I I see the Incarnation and the
crucifixion and the resurrection as this
heralding in of of not only a new age
but is the pivot of History totally
in the year of Our Lord zero A.D
you're saying and this time we're living
in between 1960 and 2040. this is this
is the apocalypse and that's why it's
also exciting and that's why
I'm wearing my horn hat and that's why
we're there's a million people on DC and
that's why we're all getting so excited
and energetic but then I'm saying what
if
how are you so sure
because I've seen it
I've seen it and uh so many of my other
visions of the future have come true so
you know it's a faith walk
and you have to go through the steps to
get there it's not just going to happen
I'm not I can't just sit back and not do
any interviews and not talk about it and
not work for it for it to not happen you
have to work for it but I'm willing to
work for it I hope you are you know if
you in the this is weird like
transmitting this Vision to others comes
into play so think about it like this
Klaus Schwab
talking about how everybody in the world
is going to wear uniforms live in
15-minute cities and eat bugs and you
got people that are absolutely outraged
by that I'm laughing my rear end off
because you thought yeah yeah yeah
that's gonna happen good luck with that
Mecca in a 15-minute City not gonna
happen not gonna happen yeah and most
people it's not gonna happen so I laugh
at him I don't get angry at him now the
people that are getting angry what
they're allowing them to allowing Cloud
Schwab to do is fill their minds with
his vision of the future and in the
process he's plugging the collective
consciousness of humanity with that
vision of the future and he is co-opting
our creative abilities our abilities to
manifest and the law of attraction to
bring that reality that he wants into
this world no you know you've referred
to the manifesting and Law of Attraction
a couple of times and as I understand it
the idea of manifesting is this idea
that I can through my my psychic powers
and my will
make things happen in the world that I
can but but not not in the sense that
you know I I will for a glass of orange
juice and therefore I'm going to go to
the fridge and pour the glass orange
juice but that it's deeper that I can in
a way cause the universe to bend perhaps
to my will is that my
it's a misconception okay so it actually
does have something to do with your
ability to go to the fridge and get
yourself some orange juice okay okay
it's think say do so you think something
so you have a vision of what you want to
do right you think it which that is a a
higher level dimension of reality that
you are accessing okay right because
you're envisioning yourself doing
something then you pick up your
three-dimensional body you move it
through the fourth dimension of time and
then you make that fifth dimensional
reality that you just imagined a
three-dimensional Reality by pouring
yourself some orange juice and drinking
it so then manifesting is just well no
no there's more to it okay there's more
to it okay
so are you familiar with the observer
effect in quantum physics yes okay it's
the idea that uh a particle is also a
wave a possibility yeah and that your
observation creates such a thing will
affect that is correct okay
Schrodinger's cat you know sure
um so
look at it like this the double slit
experiment
the observer effect all of it plays into
something called Quantum computation
so our brain does something called
Quantum computation with 40 or 40 times
every single second
we are collapsing the infinite amount of
possibilities into a singular actuality
and this is happening boom boom boom
boom boom 40 times every second right
and it's kind of like a movie reel you
know
where it's one picture after another
after another after another creating a
moving image
okay now
what I was saying earlier about the DNA
and the sending and receiving of light
and information
right our brains all the way down to our
bodies are sending and receiving light
and information we are an antenna for
non-local Consciousness we are sending
information light codes electromagnetic
codes to the universe okay with our
minds electricity electric and
electrical signal and then through the
magnetic system of the heart we are
manifesting or drawing magnetically to
us that reality the heart is the
strongest electromagnetic field in the
body
okay this is why Christ said
knock in the door will be open to ask it
shall be given to you ask and you shall
receive okay and basically you have to
be thankful in your prayer prayers of
gratitude basically be thankful for the
the father already knows thy prayer
right so Christ was teaching people the
mysteries of life and manifestation this
is what I'm saying the shamans the
shamans knew but so if manifest if men
of the station is just I ask God for
something and then God and in his
Sovereign will gives it to me or doesn't
then it doesn't seem any different no
that's not quite that's not quite it
what you have to understand is your body
is a tool okay okay and it's a tool to
send and receive electromagnetic signals
okay okay now actually on that point yes
Jacob
one way that we send signals and receive
signals is when we log on onto the
internet on any device and when people
do that if they want to protect their
privacy
they need to check out expressvpn I'm
something of a Luddite I don't like to
live my life on technology and yet so
much of what we do is recorded online
and then what happens those big tech
companies those big government actors
those nasty fellows who want your data
they get your data every website you go
to every video that you watch every
search query that you put into your
browser they see that sort of thing
unless you're using expressvpn
expressvpn will encrypt all of your data
you will not need to worry about any of
those big Tech eavesdroppers coming in
and by the way when you use my code
expressvpn.com
Michael YT letter y letter T you will
get three extra months for free so what
are you waiting for this is so simple to
use even I can do it you just download
the app on your phone on your computer
on your tablet boom you click one button
very very simple you will be protected
expressvpn Dot com slash Michael y t
I rudely interrupted you
with the greatest transition of my
entire I like it
so you you say our bodies
transmit signals and so the the
manifesting is a little different than
what a Christian would traditionally
think of as a prayer not no no not at
all okay so it is it's a form of prayer
but the thing is is that what we're
talking about is
conscious prayer and unconscious prayer
okay
so are you familiar with the work of
Greg Braden no he has a book called The
Lost mode of prayer where he actually
talks very heavily about what Christ
talked about and how to pray and how
Christ was an ancient a scene which is
like a cast of the Hebrew cast I've
heard that theory okay which I don't
don't totally don't prescribe to yeah
well I mean have you heard the theory of
John Allegro the guy that wrote The
Sacred Mushroom in the cross no and
about Jesus eating psychedelic mushrooms
oh I have heard that yeah okay I
certainly don't subscribe to that well
I'm sure you don't but the thing is I'm
telling you it's true
um but anyway that's either here nor
there the point is is that
what we're talking about here is using
the mind and the body like a computer
okay so when you get on a computer
what's happening is that an electrical
charge is going through the conductors
in the computer system itself it's
channeling through microchips which are
made of metal right and the pattern of
energy as it moves through those
microchips is governed by software or an
algorithm a mathematical algorithm and
as that feedback loop continues over and
over and over again a very specific
pattern gets created right then that
pattern ends up manifesting as code on
the screen that we are able to then
interpret and and change based on The
Strokes of the keyboard and how that
affects this pattern of electricity in
the saw in the hardware does that all
make sense basically yeah okay so the
brain and the body are like that
Hardware
and non-local Consciousness is like that
energetic signal yeah that is moving
through the mind and the body and we
because we are interconnected to the
whole of everything to this unified
field through changing our thoughts and
our emotions are therefore changing the
pattern of electromagnetic activity in
and around our bodies and therefore in
the ecosystem now I see how beginning
with your premises I see now I can
understand how one would reach that
conclusion and I have to ask
shifting topics a little bit but related
in this way
on interconnection
did you just come up with this stuff
yourself or did you discover this stuff
yourself or like what are your family
and friends think about these views do
they share your views or is it are you
unique in this way no for you know uh
yes they believe some of the things that
I believe my family in particular they
don't have
the ability to articulate it the way
that I do or memorize it the way that I
have
um
speaking of interconnectivity I mean
it's all it's all Quantum entangled the
entire universe is quantum entangled so
this information is at everybody's
fingertips
everybody can get at this level where
they have all this information they know
all this data they experience things
that are hyper dimensional they've you
know gone out of body and done astral
projection and gone to the Sun or
whatever you know anybody can do it the
question is is who's brave enough to try
go to the sun oh yeah dude dude you can
travel all over the solar system you can
travel to other star systems man how do
you do that astral projection
like what we're talking about is called
by location that the government looked
into it they called it remote viewing
they just used it as a weapon to figure
out what the heck the Soviets were doing
but you can do it fine you can fly into
the upper atmosphere of the of this of
the planet you can go to the sun you
know I've walked across the surface of
the Sun
I wasn't oh dude it was freaking awesome
wasn't as hot as you might think it
wasn't as hot as Phoenix Arizona today
pretty hot yeah you know
um I've expanded my Consciousness to to
sizes and scales that most people can't
fathom but that's because I understand
the physics of it and I understand the
metaphysics of it
I have two reactions to what you've just
told me which seem like they're kind of
opposites one is
there is a
there is a concept of by location in the
Christian tradition and great Saints
have been able to buy locate and so I
don't I know there are going to be a lot
of people watching this who say what the
hell are they talking by location that's
the craziest thing that's not the
craziest thing I've ever heard I've
heard of great Saints doing it and I see
no reason why our Lord in miraculous
ways could uh
that makes such things happen in the
natural world that he created I have no
theological problem with that at all but
then on the flip side of it
um
how do you know that you did it you know
couldn't you just have been imagining
what the sun was like well here's the
thing yes and no
there has been a number of
synchronicities that have occurred after
I've done things like this where I'm
just like
like that actually happened like I knew
what I was experiencing and I had the
faith the size of a mustard seed that
that it was possible and so it became a
reality for me what are some of these
synchronicities
oh like
so
creating storms lightning storms
thunderstorms rain and watching it
happen
um dude like if I were to tell you you
would believe me I had the video
evidence I'm not going to share it just
yet but there's dude there's things I've
accomplished that are unbelievable and
it's so cool because the thing is like
well I'm special I'm nothing special you
can do these things too I could teach
you how to do them you just have to have
faith the size of a mustard seed to do
it
you know oh yeah dude like I I could go
on and on and on I'm writing a book
right now an autobiography
um I also have videos about it that are
out there but they got taken down by
YouTube when my my social media got
taken down and I haven't released them
yet because I have all this public like
you know recognition now if I were to
come out and say okay guess what you
know they'd be like that guy is nuts and
I would much rather have people be
invested in Tesla Tower technology and
Dr Rife right now than their own ability
to buy locate the reason I ask about the
friends and the family is because
you know maybe they say look Jacob we
love you buddy but uh you're completely
insane this is the craziest thing I ever
heard do they react that way or or do
they buy it well the thing is is I have
family members that have had paranormal
experiences have been in the backyard
with me when we've all seen UFOs or uaps
and that are completely unexplainable
um I've also had family members have
very similar experiences to myself
regarding
um Deja vu's the predictions of the
future before we get to Deja everyone
predictions I have to
I have a an issue with my colleague and
my friend Matt Walsh and we argue I
don't believe in aliens he believes in
Aliens it's the whole thing
you say you've seen UFOs
is it ale you believe in aliens or no
they're not aliens okay so look at it
like this do you believe in angels and
demons yes okay angels and demons are
interdimensional entities UFOs or
extraterrestrials are interdimensional
entities we are talking about entities
that exist in Dimensions that are
layered on top of our own but that we
don't perceive with our five senses this
is part of the role of the shaman so
you're saying what this is what I say I
say either people are just imagining the
alien stuff or they're demons and you're
basically saying that I'm right and Matt
Walsh is wrong no what I'm saying is
that they're Angels or demons and you
can judge a tree by its fruits now think
about it in the Bible whenever anybody
saw an angel what was one of the first
things the angel said Be not Afraid Be
not Afraid yes exactly because when you
experience these things it is so
boundary dissolving it is so
intimidating because it's so
interdimensionally incredible that the
first inclination is to be afraid right
an evil interdimensional entity wants
people to be afraid because they feed on
that
right
Angelic or a positive interdimensional
entity is gonna say don't be afraid it's
all good I'm here to help but sometimes
the Christian view is that demons
sometimes disguise themselves as angels
of light so they pretend to be really
nice but they're evil yes well
you judge a tree by its fruits vet the
spirits right you know test the spirits
um
an angel is never going to ask you to
hurt yourself or somebody else
an angel might ask you to go through
something difficult
but there's larger interdimensional
implications to that difficult Journey
this is why shamans go through ordeals
this is why Christ did the 40 days and
40 nights in the desert it's why he went
through the passion because he
understood the interdimensional
implications for Humanity as a whole for
generations to come for Millennia to
come behind doing these things and
banishing evil from Israel when 40 days
in the 40 nights get behind me Satan you
know or the passion and going through
that and then Rising three days later
which I believe that Christ did rise but
I think it's because he achieved
something called rainbow body which
they've talked about in Tibet for a very
long time which is essentially spiritual
Ascension rainbow body rainbow body you
can look it up it's mind-blowing stuff
there's there's images of people
achieving rainbow body inside of a cave
and there are these massive rainbows all
over their silhouette and then outside
the cave there's like Footprints or hand
prints where they've vitrified their
prints into stone you know what
vitrification is where rock becomes
glass oh it gets heated so high that it
becomes glass
so there's also what happens is that
with rainbow body is that rainbows start
wafting off of the person's body and
along with those rainbows come the scent
of like Jasmine and perfumes and like
roses and stuff like that very pleasant
sounds like the month of June in
Greenwich Village you know there's a lot
of rainbows a lot of lavender and
perfume coming off people's but they're
not Angels well well this has been
documented over a hundred thousand times
in Tibet and what happens is that the
body shrinks down to like a Cabbage
Patch doll body of Ash
right and then they have these shrines
where they like put this these these
these beings in these shrines to prove
rainbow body exists that it's real and
then Above This Cabbage Patch doll body
of Ash you see this person's rainbow
body their soul they have literally
ascended and they can do whatever they
want in the physical world they have
ascended Beyond it and that's why I
think that I've heard once that in the
Shroud of Turin that it's not actually
blood but it's actually burn marks so
it's burn marks because he ascended to
this level of rainbow body in the Shroud
of Turin
in as much as we have a an explanation
of the Shroud of Turin which as the the
image of
what looks like a guy who was tortured
and crucified
um
it's a it's a photographic negative
so it would it wouldn't be paint it
wouldn't be blood or anything like that
it would be it would be right in a way
that's not totally dissimilar from what
what you're describing so
so you you believe in the resurrection
but not in the unique resurrection of
Christ and you're saying we kind of
could all access this by raising our
Consciousness and that's part of what
you're doing so then like I keep going
back and forth here as I hear more about
your
life and your vision because on the one
hand it seems so Pie in the Sky on the
other hand it seems so uh nuts and bolts
you know I'm going to go to the Capitol
on this day or I'm go I'm going to
support this candidate over this
candidate or we're going to build this
kind of tower not this kind of tower but
then on the flip side we're talking
about the age of Aquarius and going to
visit the Sun and rainbow bodies and
stuff like that
so in the short term
in the next
six months one year or two we're coming
up on a presidential election I don't
know
what what are you after
well
spiritual Ascension peace love unity
Freedom forgiveness
progra like evolutionary progress you
know for Humanity for the planet saving
the saving humanity and saving the
planet in all life thereon that's what
I'm after yeah but what else saving the
Seventh Generation
okay because that is very much in
Jeopardy right now not just our own
Seventh Generation but all over the
planet all species plant animal fungus
amphibian insect alike and so how will
you do it you'll write books you'll give
media interviews like this one I think
this is your first six big big one big
ones yes you've gotten out of out of
jail
will you are you supporting one
candidate over another candidate
politically well I don't much like Ron
DeSantis to be honest with you there's a
number of things that he's done that I
just don't agree with
um there's also a number of things that
Trump has done I don't agree with but I
support Trump for
many reasons you know
I'll put it this way though I don't
think any candidate right now is saying
what truly needs to be said
what needs to be said
well that's quite another conversation
entirely as a
um
what needs to be said is not the raw raw
raw talking points regard to secure the
Border you know the Biden Administration
is a travesty uh we need to get our
economy back on track I mean
Mike Pence is like a great example of of
rhino Republican like the interview we
did with Tucker Carlson it's like God
I can't believe he's actually running it
was tough yeah it's it's cringe you know
um so
all of even even God lover even Carrie
Lake they're all kind of saying the same
stuff nobody's explaining how it is that
we got here
nobody's explaining how it is that we're
going to move forward nobody's thinking
centuries ahead
everybody's talking about two years from
now or a year and a half from now the
next election it's like bro if we
learned anything from the Trump
Administration four years of having uh
one of our guys in office is not enough
and it's it's a fourth of the problem so
let's talk about that the bureaucracy
the Deep State the Deep state is
comprised of all three branches of
government legislative judicial and
executive being Consolidated into a
single
branch of government that is
constituting a fourth branch of
government it's a bureaucracy and this
is what the founders defined as tyranny
that's why they split the branches up
because the crown owned judicial
legislative and executive they could
write the laws and force the laws and
adjudicate the laws okay that was
tyranny that's why the founders split it
up and had checks and balances okay the
bureaucracy these bureaucratic agencies
which there are over 500 of them that
are in charge with regulating Commerce
okay they write the regulations for
Commerce in other words they're writing
a form of law okay and then they have
their own law enforcement for their
agency that enforce those regulations so
that's executive so now they got
legislative you got executive and they
have their own administrative courts
that are outside of the federal court
system that's judicial that's tyranny
okay that is and it's these bureaucrats
and these bureaucratic agencies that are
colluding with corporate interest
International corporate interests
International banking interests to move
money from public hands into private
hands so I I agree that most candidates
are just talking about fairly
superficial quotidian kind of things and
not getting to deeper problems but when
it comes to the bureaucracy and this
issue of unelected unaccountable people
writing most of the laws
I think most of the GOP candidates
actually are kind of mentioning it at
the very least I'm not explaining it to
Santa Fe yeah they're not explaining it
are they no they're just saying the Deep
State we got to drain the spot yeah it's
the Deep State oh it's a deep State it's
the boogeyman basically and it's like
well unless you understand the root of
the problem and if you can't explain it
simply you don't understand it fully so
these people need to explain simply if
they expect people to believe they can
solve the problem they need to explain
simply what the problem is and nobody's
done that yet that I can see okay I just
explained it to you in two and a half
minutes
okay and I can also explain to you how
we can change it in two and a half
minutes okay all you have to do is get
enough people in the legislative branch
to create legislation that either
changes or defunds these bureaucratic
agencies
simple as that
and so that means you have to have
somebody in the white house that is in
agreement with that agenda and you have
to have somebody in the legislative
brand and enough people in the
legislative branch that are for that
agenda that see the problem and want to
fix it
but the thing is is that the people that
are in DC that are representing the
people are actually representing these
corporations that are working with a
bureaucracy
they're representing the banks that are
working with the bureaucracy and the fed
you see what I'm saying so
it's getting Trump in office in 2024 is
only a fourth of the problem because if
we don't have the Congress then we don't
have anything it's a stalemate and if we
have the Congress and the the the White
House okay that's cool but how many
people in the Congress are willing to
dismantle the corrupt bureaucracy now
it's not all about defunding these
agencies a lot of it what it's about is
restructuring them getting people like
fauci out and putting somebody in that
isn't going to stand in the way of
things like cures for cancer
isn't going to take all this public
money and put it in the private hands of
the pharmaceutical companies you see and
that's across the board is that there's
people like fauci in every single
administrative
uh bureaucratic agent so would you run
for office
you know Gandhi never ran for office and
he did a lot of good I don't like the
idea of having to do all that paperwork
you know I they make it difficult on
purpose you also if you're going to run
for like president or something you need
to like spend like I think it's like 100
Grand to apply or something like that
it's expensive yeah yeah and I don't
have that kind of money you know I don't
so red
what I want to do is I want to hold the
people that are running accountable and
if they can't say what it is that I'm
saying then that is contrasting their
legitimacy
if somebody that's wearing horns and
face paint can understand the problems
of the world and explain them more
simply than somebody that's running for
president we have a problem
I agree
that that would represent a major
problem Jacob
it has been a great pleasure to get to
pleasure has been mine thank you thank
you for sitting down
uh best of luck in all of your future
endeavors and I suppose we'll look
forward to part two when you can speak
more openly after this uh motion motion
resolves itself hopefully happily thank
you thank you God bless
foreign